[музика]
наші Захисники які відвойовують
Херсонську область вони там знаходять
кавуни і кажуть Я вже її в Херсонській
кавун і це така прямо натхнення ти знаєш
що скоро ти будеш все їсти Я відчуваю що
ти йдеш в Європі тобі ніхто не кажеш цю
українців Чи трошки почали поважати а
поважаю тоді коли я розумію що ми
сильний ти працюєш переселенцями бо я я
їжа а їжа в першу чергу треба тим хто Ну
коли нема домівок раніше коли ти
приїжджав в Європу казав про Україну
було відношення дивнувати зараз Ти коли
відчуваєш себе в Україні ти відчуваєш що
ти йдеш в Європі тобі ніхто не кажеш але
ці українців всі трошки почали поважати
а поважаю тоді коли розуміють що ми
сильний і ми мужні і нас з нами почали
рахуватись у нас почали слухати а
головне те що змінилось до нас
відношення можливо люди втомилися від
війни але вони не втомилися від України
вони лише тільки зараз відкрили для себе
справжню Україну Я думаю що тільки
останніх 2-3 місяці люди в Європі почали
до українців відноситись як до рівних а
не як до тих хто там
досить бігає немає там щось немає змоги
там Ну десь живуть біля Росії Зараз ми
стали по відчуттям європейською
відношення отримали європейське і тепер
Наша задача давати наш рівень
європейським не порушувати там правила
дорожнього руху інколи хтось порушує чув
не порушувати
правила країн яких ти мешкаєш а навпаки
давати щось своє і посилювати ці країни
в яких ти знаходишся найсильніше що ми
можемо зробити Зараз ми можемо працювати
культурою ми можемо культурно кричати і
робити щоб це було цікаво коли ти
говориш Що він навіть війна організм
людини він відштовхує ось це щось
негативне бо вони і війна це завжди
негативне і мозок не може жити довго
жити в цьому стресі Тим паче Якщо це не
пов'язано з твоєю країною То ти не хочеш
і уникаєш з цього всього але по тій
причині що Україна у всіх на вустах люди
готові пізнавати Україну але вони готові
пізнавати з іншої сторони не просто лише
війна А що вони там їдять ці українці що
вони там вообще музикою яку слухають що
у них відбувається не виходять якесь
традицій людям цікаво стала Україна По
тій причині що просто такий інтерес бо
все все вже люди Там знають як як хто
живе в Мексиці яка там мексиканська
Кухня ці також буріто спасти піся там в
Італії а що в Україні і такого не знають
тому те що я роблю Я намагаюся показати
інший кут України Я працюю на
культурному фронті і ця культурний фронт
в мене такий досить Широкий і через це
намагаюся говорити з європейцями
європейські слухають чують бо їм Вони
їдять і відчувають наче вони на ну з'їли
щось нове щось не з щось цікаве наче
пізнали якусь секрет якийсь такий крутий
і розуміють що Україна частина Європи
або продукти не не не якісь там
екзотичні А ти що можна купити
плюс-мінус в багатьох країнах Європи але
вони по-іншому приготовані з іншими
традиціями і це дає величезний
величезний результат Це просто багато
різних традиційних українських страв але
вони
[музика]
або вони перестали існувати По тій
причині що люди їх не їли або вони ще не
почали існувати Але чи Мене називають
традиційними бо вони на нашій території
в тій чи іншій в тих чи іншій е-е
частині вони проявляються і е-е я
використовую це таке спрощення під
назвою слово традиційність тому
наприклад перша страва це була банош
банош Ми готували Готується з білими
грибами і білі гриби я не зміг привести
не зміг купити Тому це звичайно
шампіньйони але приготував так що вони
були дуже схожі по ароматикою на білі
гриби ти отримав просто банош з білими
грибами я казав про те що що це таке всі
кажуть це пеленти я кажу ні Це банош а
вони в сенсі кажу що баноші коленти є
різниця але вони дуже схожі полента
Готується з водою напевно готуючись з
вершками і у нас Ми є так само як є в
Італії страви такі наші є і ви нас і
вони були щоб люди в шоці в Європі бо Ну
я думаю що у нас щось зовсім інше А я
кажу ні у нас таке який в Європі і була
страва я дякував по посольствую і Польщі
і дякував польським на польскому народу
за те що вони допомагають нам і її
органів допомагають багато тому назвав
страву проти судак запечений з соусом
Журик я взяв Журик традиційно як він
готується треба закваскою цю закваску
так зверху на рибу як соус вилові це
така найновіша моя подяка також були
вареники але вареники всі в Україні
кажуть це українська страва якою що вона
як Українська так і польська тому немає
сенсу за них воювати вони не треба вони
це наша страва але те що в нас унікальне
- це саме начинка тому я зробив вареники
з з маком і з вишнею і двома матки вишня
нема у поляків Нема нікого в світі це
лише наша унікальність е-е ну і там було
ще одна справа буженина з індичка це
такий смак ми завжди його буженину на
Великдень А я зробив буженину а з тим
самими смаками але просто з інших
продуктів ти її сонце наче бужинина наче
наче геть не вона
Ну е-е ось це так коротко та те що я
готував а були були ще кавун багато в
Україні і люди їдять їли кавуна раніше
за багатьох книжках прямо Багато людей
їдять хліб з кавуном багато хто їсть
кавун заселяться багато хто їсть кавуни
з медом хтось їсть гострим перцем це
така абсолютно нормальна річ для України
але вона така перший раз дивна тому що я
зробив кавун поклав вас складець поклав
квашеного огірок бо це все традиційні
питання для України трішки хліба ну і
бджоли бо я не зміг додати мед бо я не
привів свої мед а бджоли легенькі їх
може легко через кордон паровозити Я
поклав бджіл боїться моя фірмова фішка в
думку про те що це наші меди не привіз
але бджоли Вони мають тільки відношення
до мети Тому поки на Херсонській але я
бачу багато відео вони з'являються наші
Захисники які відвойовують херсонського
область вони там знаходять кавуни і
кажуть Я вже їх в Херсонській кавун і це
така приємна натхнення ти знаєш що скоро
ти будеш все їсти те щоб борщ навіть
більш людей цього одно точно але є
зовсім інший ефект якого я не очікував
який я спостерігаю зараз за останні
місяці в Україні відбулося зміна у людей
в Україні в Україні ті хто за кордоном
Вони почали по-іншому відноситись до
своєї справи раніше є таке фестиваль
називається burned фестиваль де всі
тусяць свобода і вільність там ніхто
ніколи не міг додуматись до того Ну там
кожен будує якусь свою станцію зараз
побудували станцію борщу де людям не
соромно по в пустелі де куча модних
людей давати борщ раніше Вони б
стидалися цього бочці ж домашній і
просте А тепер вони відкрили точку де в
пустелі готують борщ бо вони знають що
це настільки горда і те що мені Нам
вдалося змінити
відношення до борщу українців це не
просто домашня страва А це стала
гордістю компанія одна яка робить
хустинки в дуже відома нішева випустила
позавчора Ну на днях випустила хустинку
з борщем вона вважає що це стильно це
мода вважає що вирішити коли йшов в тебе
було написано борщ Ну ти хто ти що А
знаєте хто написано борщ Ти поважна
людина і ось ця зміна свідомості людей і
люди по всьому світу почали українці
по-іншому Вони почали кричати про гроші
раніше вони стидалися цього зараз ні і
оце їхні дії Лише зараз починають
починають змінювати суспільство я б
думаю 1,5-2 роки і світове суспільство
буде 100% всіх кожен знати так само
добре як рамен суп так само буде і борщ
так само як іменно зараз лише почалися
зміни але вони такі вже почалися які не
мають зворотнього шляху і зараз
найкрутіший час треба сидіти і кайфувати
І насолоджуватись тим поки протягом двох
років борщ буде везде і буде
завойовувати душу його голови країни
людей в світі в мене війна зустріла в
Києві О 4:30 мені в четверті 40 мені
подзвонила а
моя партнер по бізнесу як тільки був
перший вибух через три хвилини мене він
подзвонила сказала що треба прокидатися
в мене телефон був е-е вимкнений Я не
знаю як воно додзвонилися е-е але в мене
була зібрана валізка тривожна і через 5
хвилин Я вже був в машині а через 7
хвилин забрав свою сестру і через ще
навіть не було Не корок Не було нічого
ще навіть сонце не встала Я вже був за
містом Бо ніхто нічого не знав що
відбувається Сказав Треба передать Київ
Я дуже швидко це зробив а потім вже Я не
міг повернутися в Київ бо туди ніколи не
пускало тому така ситуація що я був 70
км під Києвом а просто в такій бо я дуже
швидко все зробив я навіть не встиг
подумати що мені робити залишатися їхати
цим займатися бо тоді ще інформації не
було два дні ресторан був зачинений на
третій день ресторан відкрився для Не
для людей а для тероборони для тих людей
які будуть чекали Ну були в метро то
есть ми годували десь півтори тисячі
порцій кожен день волонтери привозили
продукти вместе проти готували їжу ось
наші справи був як і бомбосховище як так
само як і е-е місце де ми підготували
годували те що могли робити тому
ресторан був 3000 грн лише два дні
відчуття Відчуття того що Ми навіть не
закривались я як волонтер Я не зовсім
їжджу на фронт бо є багато людей які
їздять мені туди сенсу ніхто не має але
я підтримую переселенців Я працюю з
переселенцями бо я я їжа я їжа в першу
чергу треба тим хто Ну коли нема доміво
кого немає змогу купити їжу тому я в
тилу займаюся тим що я відкрию два
заклади які годують для пере- готують
переселенців І до сих пір'ї зараз я
відкрию цех по виробництву різних
консервацій по типу Куліша по типу
шпундер типу типу борщу для того щоб
допомагати людям які прифронтових зонах
не можуть не виїхати і не можуть нічого
купити поїсти ми разом з
внесенням міжнародного шпанд ми
закуповуємо на просторі набори і
передаємо
в авдіївку передаємо в ті місця де
потрібно це найбільше Тож у нас
підтримка через їжу бо ми власне
європейська командами є їжа Ми не можемо
робити нічого іншого крім цього ну
можемо звичайно але ми вважаємо що в
цьому суперсильний цукор професіонали і
нам треба це робити події Я думаю що
будуть розгортатися ніхто не знає якби
це війна і під час війни всіх експерти
які говорять Це просто фраза і слова і
мало хто що знає може спрогнозувати
декілька сценаріїв Я вважаю що не
сценарій точно ми будемо воювати Ми
переможемо а от що таке слово перемога з
кожним вкладає собі хтось один думає що
ми відвойовуємо всі території а Хтось
думає про те що ми відновимося
економічно а Хтось думає про те що ми
Росія впаде під санкціями там Можливо
там помре Путін у кожного своє розуміння
Перемоги але ми точно знаємо що вона
настане і вона на власне вона й настає
для кожного українця коли він не падає
духом А коли кожен українець
бореться і продовжує боротися тільки ти
розумієш що не можна здаватися це вже є
перемога Бо якби ти впав духом то це
була поразка і тому я вважаю що ми вже
перемогли і перемагаємо просто той
момент якийсь офіційний як ми звикли до
перемоги там 9 травня раніше було
перемога наче все зупинилося Я не думаю
що в мене до цього близький Але ми дуже
близькі в голові що кожен з нас переможе
якщо вся нація буде думати що вона
перемагає ти не можеш перемогти якщо я
граю в спорті не можеш перемогти у нації
яка вважає що вони переможці ти можеш
там
випригувати що робити що хочеш але коли
йдеш на людей А вони А вони переможці ти
наскільки не був ти програєш бо в нас
інших філософія Я покидаю країну на те
наскільки мені дозволяє Міністерство
культури України бо за їх сприянням Я
завжди У нас є громадська організаціями
ми подаємо бажання кажемо що ми будемо
проводити деякі заходи Будемо збирати
гроші для України Міністерство
міністерства культури просить держпри
соціальна служба каже виплачуть для того
щоб зробити і підтримати Україну у нас
опускають тому
можна зайти в базу перевірити і всі
питання з них ми вважаємо по сім по 8
днів Він коли бувають 3-4 дні Це все так
само як виїжджають співаки і співати Так
само виїжджаємо ми бо я майже співав
тільки я готую і не співати